[Music]
well the United States really since the
end of the Cold War has launched a
project to try and spread you might call
a liberal world order in many parts of
the world we started the 1990s thinking
that democracy free markets and lots of
other good things were spreading almost
automatically but the Clinton
administration decided to give it a
shove with NATO expansion with a number
of other programs designed to spread
democracy in various places and then of
course the Bush administration took it
to the next level with the invasion of
Iraq but this didn't stop under the
Obama administration which of course
tried to topple Muammar Gaddafi as well
so this is a bipartisan product of
democratic liberal internationalists and
republican neoconservatives and the
basic idea is to try and spread
something like the american system in as
many places around the world as we could
the problem is this doesn't work very
well it failed in Iraq it's failing in
Afghanistan it failed in Yemen it failed
in Libya and it's not looking
particularly good in places like Hungary
and Poland which are starting to show
certain liberal signs
moreover the optimism people once had
about Russia becoming a member of the
Democratic family of Nations I think
have been disappointed as well now why
does this fail
well first problem of course is that
spreading democracy into other countries
inevitably means regime change you've
got to get rid of the existing
government and replace it with something
new but of course when you take apart an
existing order you can't be sure what
the new orders going to look like and
you're gonna create a lot of angry
losers people who are resentful at their
loss of power and status and in some
places like Iraq or Libya they're able
to take up arms to resist this effort so
simultaneously you create an incentive
for resistance an incentive for
insurgency and by destroying the
existing order you could also create an
open space where terrorists and other
extremists can flourish so a big problem
first is you're beginning by tearing
apart a new order without knowing how to
replace it that really is the second
problem we don't know how to
create viable democracies in other
countries and especially in countries
that have never been democratic before
where there are deep ethnic divisions
where they're not necessarily very
prosperous and we ought to remind
ourselves that it took 200 years or more
for democracy to emerge in the West that
was a violent and contentious process
and to believe as we did in say 2003
that we could invade Iraq and create a
shiny new pro-american democracy in five
or ten years was positively delusional
and I think you see this in one final
way when the United States ends up
owning one of these countries it has to
occupy it as to try and keep order but
it doesn't know enough about the inner
workings of that society which people
are reliable which people can be trusted
to do the kind of social engineering
that creating a new nation or creating a
new system of government would entail so
recently Afghanistan a local American
commander had to apologize for issuing a
propaganda leaflet which included the
flag of the Taliban some quranic' verses
and an image of a dog dogs are regarded
in parts of the Islamic world as unclean
and to associate that with the Quran of
course was deeply offensive to many of
the Muslims for whom it was intended now
I mentioned this only because the United
States has been in Afghanistan for 16
years and we still haven't fully figured
out how to operate in that society in
order to have sort of reliable positive
effects the bottom line here is this
well-intentioned effort to spread
American values American institutions
into many different corners of the world
has been an almost complete failure and
if the United States wants to promote
its values it ought to devote much more
effort to creating a exemplary democracy
here in the United States so that other
countries will look at the United States
say I'd like to have something like that
and then build their version of it it's
something that we can do leading by
example but not leading
the military edge two more good
illustrations of our inability to do
nation-building in many parts of the
world are the failed effort to create a
new democracy in Libya there's an
uprising in Libya as a consequence of
the Arab Spring and the United States
and several of its Democratic allies
especially France and Britain decide to
intervene on behalf of the rebel forces
now this was originally intended or so
we said as a purely humanitarian act to
prevent Muammar Gaddafi who was at that
point still in power from conducting
some cite some kind of mass killing of
the of the rebels but we quickly
expanded beyond that and gave help to
the rebels in the form of air power such
that they eventually succeeded but of
course once the Gaddafi regime which was
by all accounts a horrific inefficient
despotism but once it was gone there was
no order left and instead of a stable
effective democracy what you had instead
was the emergence of warlords factions
militants and essentially a failed state
it also involved
Libya's very considerable arms arsenal
getting spread out and scattered to a
variety of other extremist groups in
other places including Syria so the
bottom line here is a well-intentioned
effort to promote human rights and
spread democracy ends up creating a
failed state and said and that is
essentially the same story one could
tell in a place like Yemen where the
United States has repeatedly intervened
to try and promote more democratic
outcomes and where we now have another
failed state one where Saudi Arabia has
intervened with military force where
there's a cholera epidemic that's
spreading vast human suffering and the
country is further away from being an
effective democracy today than it was
when the United States first started
meddling again this just teaches us the
lesson that the United States has enough
trouble making democracy work here in
the United States itself trying to
create it in other places that have
never been democratic and especially
trying to do that with military force
simply doesn't work I think there are
a set of humanitarian circumstances
where the United States should think
about intervening and primarily when we
think there is going to be a large-scale
mass killing in the order of tens of
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people and in those circumstances we may
or may not intervene depending on first
of all whether or not we have strategic
interests that reinforce the imperative
to do more but also whether or not we
are confident that intervention is
actually going to make things better as
opposed to making things worse now an
obvious case of this is Syria there's
been a horrific civil war going on in
Syria now for more than five years
upwards of a half a million people have
died and many Americans have wanted the
United States to get more actively
involved arming one side or the other
perhaps trying to impose some kind of
no-fly zone the difficulty is it is hard
to be confident that any of those
measures are actually going to make the
situation better why because there are
really no good guys in this particular
fight and to the extent that there are
some moderate forces within the Syrian
civil war they are among the weakest and
the least likely to succeed so if the
United States were to intervene it is as
likely to bring some kind of violent
extremists some kind of al Qaeda
offshoot organizations like Isis to
power as it is to bring a bunch of nice
peace-loving pro-american liberal
Democrats so it would be nice to say
remove the Assad regime you know put him
on trial for war crimes but what we may
be leaving behind would be something
absolute that considerably worse so even
in the case of a clear humanitarian
incentive and those things those
circumstances will arise from time to
time I think we want to be careful and
only intervene when we know we can make
it better and when we also see a way to
get out so that we don't end up having
to be there for decades
[Music]